[Música]
economía en directo américa de france 24
de luis méndez conmigo en el estudio de
louis es bienvenido felices mañana de
miércoles ya mitad de semana vamos a
iniciar entonces una atención entre
rusia y ucrania porque la empresa
petrolera gazprom anunció que mantienen
suministro de gas hacia europa s luego
de cochrane anunciaron una interrupción
del tránsito de suministro de este
producto louis así es raúl hay que
señalar que esta petrolera en un primer
momento había manifestado que la acción
ucraniana que consiste en cambiar la
entrada de la entrada de flujo de gas
era imposible pero muy temprano para
occidente señaló que los envíos se
habían reducido esta reducción pasó
según la agencia de noticias reuters de
95 8 millones de metros cúbicos a unos
72 millones de metros cúbicos aunque se
desconoce si con el nivel de flujo
actual se mantiene la línea con las
solicitudes de los países europeos pero
el regulador de energía de alemania
también informó que los volúmenes de
importación se mantienen estables
ucrania había expresado que debieron una
causa de fuerza mayor era imposible
seguir transportando el gas desde el
punto de conexión de ravich ya el cual
en teoría representa un tercio del flujo
total que ucrania transporta de gas a
europa pero por otro lado recordemos que
muchos países han reducido o han vetado
la importación de hidrocarburos rusos
como medida para presionar la salida de
las tropas rusas del territorio
ucraniano por ello le respondió serguéi
lávrov el ministro de relaciones
exteriores del gobierno ruso quien se
encuentra de visita en gomas en omán
escuchemos
unos listos no tenemos suficientes
compradores para nuestros recursos
energéticos y trabajaremos con ellos
what's your ass deudor y que occidente
pague mucho más de lo que pagó a la
federación rusa y que le expliqué a su
población porque se está empobreciendo
es nuestro en vivo por medio de toda
esta situación la organización
internacional del trabajo informó que
ucrania perdió alrededor de un tercio de
sus empleos a raíz de la guerra al
tiempo que el ministro de finanzas de
ucrania
sergi para chanco informó desde
marraquech donde están reunidos los
integrantes del banco europeo para la
reconstrucción y el desarrollo que
esperan una contracción económica del
país del 45 por ciento cuanto más tarde
ucrania en ganar esta guerra más países
sentirán este efecto indirecto e
inevitable y tendrán que solicitar y
pedir financiación externa adicional
expresó en parte de sus declaraciones
louis y nos vamos hasta alemania porque
allí se dieron a conocer los datos de
inflación correspondientes a el pasado
mes de abril y es que de acuerdo con el
comunicado de prensa de la oficina
general de estadísticas tasa de
inflación alcanzó máximos históricos por
segundo mes consecutivo y que no eran
vistos desde la reunificación del país
según lo dicho por george y el
presidente de este referido organismo la
tasa de inflación se ubicó en alemania
en 74 por ciento a nivel interanual en
el mes de abril un salto de 0.1 por
ciento si tomamos en comparación con el
dato obtenido en el mar en marzo del
presente año adicionalmente mostró un
avance de 0.8 por ciento a nivel mensual
según el organismo que destaca el
aumento por parte del incremento en los
precios los productos energéticos y
también el aumento en la media del
precio de los alimentos en todo el país
hablando de aumento lo y nos venimos a
nuestra región el sur del continente
americano en argentina se oficializó el
adelanto del aumento del salario mínimo
así es raúl recordemos que en marzo tras
una serie de discusiones se había
acordado un aumento de 45 por ciento en
el salario básico el cual estaría
dividido en cuatro entregas
debido a la infracción y otros factores
dentro de argentina se tomó la decisión
previa consulta con los sectores
involucrados de adelantar estos aumentos
en marzo el incremento se había
establecido de la siguiente manera un
18% en el mes de abril que ya se cumplió
un 10% en el mes de junio un 10% en
agosto y un 7% en diciembre para ese
45% de incremento ahora se establece un
aumento de 20% en julio es decir
adelantaron el pago de agosto para el
próximo mes de junio y el de diciembre
del 7% ahora se estará pagando a partir
del mes de agosto con lo que el salario
quedaría entonces en 47 mil 850 pesos
argentinos que representan alrededor de
288 dólares al cambio del banco central
argentino los indicadores económicos hay
que ver que toda la presión que existe
en torno a la inflación y los datos que
se están dando a conocer tanto en china
alemania y próximamente en estados
unidos generaron cierres mixtos en el
mercado asiático a lo largo de la
jornadas mientras tanto en alemania
donde los mercados siguen operando
también están con ligera expectativa en
torno a lo que podría hacer los datos de
inflación en eeuu pero operan en terreno
positivo y para finalizar louis este
primer bloque económico el día que nos
trae como cifra tiene que ver en este
caso con el 2,9 por ciento que es es
según la agencia de financiación en este
caso morgan stanley lo que podría ser el
pib global una reducción de más del 50
por ciento si lo comparamos con el 6,2
por ciento que habían expresado
anteriormente louis como siempre gracias
por toda la información económica nos
vemos más adelante con más dejamos hasta
marruecos